foreign
we are back with a special 400th
400th
special we have we've done 400 episodes
100 episodes a special ask me anything
show we made 400 episodes I don't even
think I've been here for 400 episodes
[Music]
oh what's up this is John with Dr John
deloney show It's the
400th episode
400.
[Music]
if you're one of the original OG 17
listeners how much money did you lose on
this one we made 400 episodes
wow I don't even think I've been here
for 400 episodes
man we ran off James got rid of that guy
Kelly's here Jen is here Joe Andrew Emmy
dude we made 400 guys it's awesome I
mean really who would have thought when
we were down in the basement down there
the first few
I'm not sure any of us could say we
thought we'd get here
I thought I would feel so much
um
better at this job
I thought I would know what's happening
and I feel like the longer this goes the
less I know but as we do at every
hundredth of the century intervals
today is a special ask me anything AMA
derived from questions that you all have
sent in
um either via the John deloney.com ask
or on the internet's on social so Kelly
who's asking the questions today
I am you yeah good Jenna makes me
uncomfortable
not really that's not nice you asked
questions the other day actually I'm not
gonna lie she did a great job of course
she said no mean things to me and my
headphone
well yeah I'm still working on it yeah
you kept them all in your in your heart
in my head that was fantastic I loved it
it made me happy all right so let's do
this let's make internet uh magic all
right the first question can a marriage
work without intimacy
no but I'm gonna caveat it
um I think we
so
so most people say sex
people in polite company especially
people in faith context often don't say
the word sex they say the word intimacy
or people who are trying to be proper
say intimacy so if we're using the word
intimacy to mean sexual intercourse yes
you can have a great and wonderful
marriage without sexual intercourse on
the regular particularly as you get
older as you age Etc
um the key here is it's it's something
that has to be navigated and discussed
and negotiated together it can't be one
person deciding this is the way this is
going to be and the other person's got
to live with it
um but I take a much broader view of
intimacy intimacy is a connection at the
soul level at the intention level in at
the every minute of my day I'm thinking
of ways I can meet my partner's needs
and they're trying to meet mine intimacy
is about doing the things that I know
help you have a better life and in turn
you're doing the things that help me
have a better life and so in intimacy is
reciprocal and it is connectedness and
is together
um and so no I don't think you can have
a marriage without that
without a shared connectivity but yes
as you get older there's medical issues
as your sexual interest like actual like
doing it doing it wanes and other things
are more important like I just want to
sit here on the front porch and hold
your hand and like that can be deeply
intimate moments the key again is that
they're discussed is that is that fair
yeah because like you I think it's more
than I think the question is asked well
I'm asking it so I know what it is
um it's not just sex it's yeah it's
beyond just sex it's because intimacy
intimacy is more than that we've talked
about that there's more than just that
yeah all right the second one how do you
choose your tattoos
oh man so
you usually I go with somebody and we
take seven or eight shots and I'm just
kidding we don't at all
um usually it's a couple of things one
um
like I've got tattoos down my ribs of my
children and the kids that we lost uh
the names of the children we lost
um at pregnancy and so sometimes they're
deeply meaningful the tattoos down my
back are from uh childhood stuff and
when I was trying to be a uh opposed or
want to be Fighter
um the ones down my arm are usually a
collection of things that are meaningful
to me and or
um kind of dealer's choice and so I
think I've talked about it here
I was try I travel a lot and so I just
decided I was gonna start getting new
tattoos in every city and so sometimes
man there was some pretty sketchy things
but usually it's something that means
something important to me
all right how do you choose yours
just let's that's coming up another
question oh is it
how did we let go of blame
um
blame is good for for honestly
evaluating how I ended up in a certain
situation
um somebody shoved me now I'm in the
middle of the road
that's helpful info
but it doesn't get me out of the middle
of the road
and so I get over blame
honestly because it has absolutely no
help it's of no help to me and going
where I go next unless
um I know I'm not going to go back on
that side of the road because that guy
just pushed me in the road right so it
might give me some direction here
um but it's not going to help me make my
next steps and so I I just think blaming
is a complete and utter waste of my time
um it just has no value what about you
you love blame and like it makes you
feel it makes your heart feel good no I
don't I don't y'all seriously
[Laughter]
that um
I have this need in like a you should
take
like you should be responsible for the
things you did
probably more to other people than I am
for myself which is not good but so I I
tend to hold on to it
um inside sometimes more than I should
so it's a Justice thing yeah
like you're wrong and so I'm gonna hold
on to this because clearly that's a good
thing to do sometimes I'm bad about that
whole you know it's like taking poison
and then hoping the other person dies
right I that's something I work on but
it's not an easy thing
um to let go of blame blames helpful for
me in reflection yeah it's like what is
it righteous
indignation yeah I feel like I'm holding
on to this because it makes you holier
than now it's a little bit of like of
that if I'm being real honest yeah I get
that it's like I exercise and that
suddenly makes it okay that I eat my
body weight and gar yeah I get it um so
I I just tend to think that blame
um
is a waste of my time and so I want to
pull that straight that that string all
the way
so let's say I was sexually abused as a
kid
and I have real challenges
um making close connected relationships
as an adult
or let's suggest that um I was
physically abused as a kid and so when
somebody's angry or somebody wants to
have a strong disagreement with me on
the basis of my ideals or my ideas like
at work or in a marriage I instantly
hide I run
those things in my childhood happened no
question about that and my body
naturally created defense mechanisms so
that those things would be less likely
to happen in the future no question
about that
but for me to continue as an adult to
blame what happened then
for the things I need to do to be well
and whole and treat people with dignity
and respect in my in my life as an adult
it does me no good it can't I can't
bring them from the past to to make
right my my present it just doesn't know
how it works and so I just tend to on
the whole
blames a waste of my time I'd rather be
about what comes next how do I get to
the next place how do I
participate in healing how do I get a
new group of people to walk alongside me
nice all right
um top favorite three top three favorite
books on parenting and relationships
you say it one more time
top three favorite books on parenting
and then top three favorite books on
relationships oh geez uh uh
um that's easily easily the most common
question I get is questions about hey
what books what books what books what
books
um I almost thought about getting a
master's degree in library science just
because of how many how often I get that
um I think my number one parenting book
of all time is is hold on to your kids
by Gabor mate and Gordon Newfield hold
on to your kids
um an absolute absolute absolute
Masterpiece everything Kapoor mate
writes is a masterpiece that guy is just
uh like an international treasure he's
from Canada otherwise he'd call him a
National Treasure
um there's another book out that I
haven't read this is me being honest I
haven't read it
um it's called baby Bomb
um by Cara hop Hopi Hoppe I think
um and she has another author Stan
something
um I've had it recommended a bunch I got
on my shelf I haven't read it but I
think it'd be worth picking up just from
the people who have recommended it to me
I highly trust
um I don't know that I have a third
probably scattered by Gabor mate it's a
book about ADHD
um but it has a broader picture about
raising kids and stress and maternal
stress and paternal stress and so that's
a phenomenal book as it as it comes to
relationships
um the new rules of marriage by Terence
real is extra ordinary
um
Come As You Are by Emily nagoski the
book on sex it's less about it's more
about a relationship between a woman and
her body but I think the men that have
read it have find extraordinary value in
it as well and I think it's a great book
that couples can read together and I um
Lori gottlieb's
is it maybe you should talk to somebody
is that right yeah
um that's a an extraordinary book as
well
um anything by
um Esther perel What About You Kelly do
you have a parenting book that means
something to you or relationship book
besides the karma sutra
parenting wise um
as a parent of a of a boy one of the
best ones we ever read was
um
David Denton who is a uh sorry David
Thomas he's a counselor local counselor
here at Daystar same place Golf
Works and he wrote a book called
um wild wild things and it is the it has
been the most referenced book in our
house for raising boys and it um does a
really good job of putting
like two to four here's who they are
four to eight here's who they are and it
talks about here's who they are
physically here's where they are
emotionally here's what they need from
Mom here's what they need from dad
here's what they need from outside
sources here's what they need
spiritually you know and then like to
the point where the point now where it's
like Mom you're not as big a part of the
picture now and that's really sucks but
so you treat me yes
well there you go
um but so here's what they need from you
and here's what they need and if there's
not a dad in the picture if there's not
a mom in the picture it's like a
handbook and it has been amazing how
closely as I've looked at that and then
watched our son he
it's been a great one and then
relationships not my favorite book
overall you mentioned it the other day
but I think it's worth it is the five
love languages
only because my husband and I are
extremely different people
and so I I finally read that when
understanding that well maybe what I'm
doing is not
is isn't working he doesn't understand
that that's my way that I show I care
gotcha and so that did a good job of the
whole idea of it like you have to learn
your partner and learn what works for
them because I can buy him gifts all day
long but if to him that doesn't mean
anything it's useless yes and so I I
agree with you there that book gives a
great it's a great conversation starter
I think
um I I personally don't think there's
just five love languages but
um I do think they that they that
provides a great basis for a place to
start and you just said it perfectly
most of us go through our lives trying
to help other people and our hearts are
good especially those that we love the
most
but we help them in ways we want to be
helped right not in ways that they're
actually
Desiring to be held right and then we
end up pushing them into the margins or
hurting them in an attempt to try to
love them right and they don't see it
they're like well gosh they must not
love me or like me or because if they
did they'd mow the lawn and we're over
here you know buying expensive gifts or
whatever so you just it's just about
getting on the same page and love it
yeah I love it um all right so those are
the great those are the books there hang
with us we'll be right back with this uh
400th episode AMA stay with us
[Music]
all right people all of us procrastinate
about something maybe you've been
ignoring your check engine light or
maybe you've been putting off plans to
read more whatever it is good sleep is
not something to put off sleep is the
foundation for your mental and physical
health and like your check engine light
your old mattress won't just fix itself
so don't procrastinate here quality
sleep starts with a great mattress like
dream cloud with their one year in-home
trial there's no excuse to keep tossing
and turning on your old mattress that
keeps getting more uncomfortable by the
night
it's time to invest in good sleep and
dream cloud is the only luxury brand
that gives you a full year to try out
your new mattress a full year stop
procrastinating I know you'll love your
dream club right away just like my
family does right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and why
not
599 dollars in accessories with promo
code John deloney that's pillows luxury
sheets and a mattress protector so go on
dreamcloudsleep.com and use promo code
John deloney today and also probably
don't ignore that check engine light for
very much longer
all right we are back with a special
400th
special we have we've done 400 episodes
100 episodes a special ask me anything
show go for it Kelly go for it all right
how can a traumatic childhood that
predates your memory impact your
development
um
well I think it goes before that so
there's some pretty remarkable it's
controversial but some pretty remarkable
research suggesting that trauma is
passed genetically
um that can actually things that happen
to your grandparents show up in their
grandkids genes that doesn't mean things
are deterministic but that just means
that the possibility that things are
going to emerge so you've probably heard
me talk on the show about genetics and
gasoline cans in the garage
um things that happen to your
grandparents can put gasoline cans in
the garage of grandkids and what that
means is a spark that might otherwise
just you know cause some smoke damage
may cause a house to explode
um and so when it comes to
trauma and an individual's childhood
even if you don't remember it
um to not sound woo-woo the body does or
as Vandercook says the body keeps the
score and so as a young kid if you learn
as an infant mom is not safe
you will begin trying to solve that
relationship
for the rest of your life your body
knows I can't do life without a close
Attunement a closely attached
relationship to my my mom or to my dad
or to my primary caregiver and so it
will continue to try to solve that
forever if you're abused as a young kid
sometimes your brain has some remarkable
mechanisms to
take that memory off the board for a
while
um or forever but your body knows when a
guy comes in the room and turns the
lights off that it's time to go to war
or something to disappear and so
um I often and I think the research
Bears this out the memory is pretty
unreliable across the board it's just
pretty unreliable I think what is a more
helpful
um way of healing and seeing the world
is
what is my body telling me right now
that what is it trying to protect me
from why is it feeling unsafe and how do
we go from here that that I'm finding
that to be an infinitely more important
question than what happened what
happened what happened I can tell you
also as a mother of two adopted children
especially my son
um that because I remember thinking oh
he's two
he won't remember there's it'll be just
like he's ours and everything's fine but
that's not the case because he was too
living in an orphanage for two years and
so he didn't have anyone that held him
he self-soothed you know so yeah and and
I can only imagine the stress that his
birth mother she was young had him early
that all of that put on
so I remember thinking that's like he
doesn't even remember this right well he
doesn't but he's got coping mechanisms
and and it's interesting how when things
get stressful like when our house
flooded I saw him do some of those same
self soothing mechanisms and he's 17.
yeah but it's because of what he reverts
to it's what he knows that's right and
if you think about both of those in
combination that
what did his birth mother in Russia
right Ukraine very different what did
her grandmother experience
right the hell that that was at the turn
of the century right so you imagine
those things getting encoded in a young
boy and then he finds himself in an
orphanite right so it I mean it's it's a
mess on top of mess and it's rare that
even in the anywhere in the world that
trauma just Springs out of a family unit
it usually comes from it rolls downhill
right so
um yeah there's a big mess when it comes
to trauma but it's it's always stopping
to ask yourself what is my body trying
to protect me from right now
I'll just say thank God for counseling
thank God for Council all right
which one of Kelly's tattoos is your
favorite oh dude the other day when you
came into work and you had your shirt
tucked in on itself and that awesome
Thug Life tattoo across your stomach was
amazing it was incredible you had you
did you had that denim shirt it wasn't
tucked in you had tied up real high and
it was like everyone was talking about
like why is Kelly showing her abs and
then you turned and that Thug Life
tattoo is happening that was awesome
that was good I could tell you've had
that for like 20 years I mean it had
faded back there in your Tupac day I
mean it was dope it was good it was good
that's my favorite one so far
I have none I have no tattoos people
I have none
we've been on the show for 400 episodes
and you still are denying core parts of
who you are done not a one I'm
considering my first one
it's gonna be a picture of John without
a picture of John with dollar signs
yes that's what it is all right next
question
I'm in ICU RN how do I know if I am
burned out or depressed
oh man
um
I'm gonna answer this in a way that's
not gonna be popular
the answer is most of the time it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
um if you get nerdy and you go down the
burnout literature and people trying to
figure out is burnout at actual
physiological thing or is it an
emotional Thing versus the depression
literature which is just so vast
um
the symptoms of those things end up very
similar and I've read that burnout you
know leads to depression or burnout is
just related to a work environment and
if you change environments and suddenly
you feel better whereas depression
sometimes
I think if you are an ICU nurse
or you're an elementary school teacher
or you're a leader or you're an attorney
or you're a doctor or whatever you're
doing man
um
if your body is telling you enough is
enough is enough
trying to sit down and figure out what
kind of enough it is is really
I mean it goes back to the old there's a
tiger at the front of your cave and
you're wondering is that a nice tiger is
that the petting tiger is that the mean
tiger it doesn't matter it's a tiger
Gotta Go Gotta Move
and so I think asking whether it's
burnout whether it's depression I think
the real question we need to ask we have
a culture so obsessed with Diagnostics
obsessed with Diagnostics what label is
the right label for you I am much more
interested in a society that really
learns to trust
it's a body
the individual bodies in this in and
also has a group of people that helps us
with that because sometimes my body lies
to me sometimes my body says she's not
safe she's super safe
and I need to check in with some people
that I trust whether it's a counselor
whether it's close friends and so I want
an ICU nurse who's struggling to wake up
in the morning who's struggling to sleep
at night
um who can't breathe who's lost interest
in things that used to bring her great
Joy or bring him great deep satisfaction
not interested in sexual connection it's
not interested in hanging out with
friends not interested in the things
that used to bring them life
whether that's a burnout whether that's
depression I don't really care
what I care about is that you honor
yourself enough to sit down with
somebody and say I'm not okay
let's go from there let's go from there
one thing isn't worth more attention
than the other
all of it's worth attention
and I contend that somebody can
um
we have to have people let me say this
way we have to have people to do these
really really really hard jobs we have
to gotta have people who are ICU nurses
or the society stops right gotta have
people who are trauma surgeons and
police officers we've got to have people
who are firefighters we have to have
sewage work we have to have these people
to show up in the middle of the mess
and then their bodies are going to
respond in particular ways and we've got
to have the support network for these
folks to stay well in holes they can
continue to go back and go back and go
back into these hard jobs so at the end
of the day I don't really think it
matters if you end up with clinical
depression your doctor the person you're
working with the counselor they will let
you know and if you need a very specific
treatment option there great that's cool
but if your body's telling you we're not
okay
don't immediately run to the labels
instead step back and look and see
what's on fire and it might be that you
need a break it might mean that you need
some support it might mean that you need
to start treating your body better it
might mean that you need some connection
with friends and Community it might mean
you need to work at a new hospital it
might mean a whole bunch of things that
um don't require a label that's that's
my thoughts
all right how many guitars do you
currently own oh
not a lot
um
I've got the Les Paul that my wife
bought me when I graduated with my first
PhD and I got the Flying V that I just
love I have an SG that I love
um and then I have a Martin acoustic and
then I have an Everett acoustic Handmade
by a dude in Atlanta and it's one of the
best sounding guitars I've ever heard in
my life and I'm gonna get a couple more
there's a couple more that I want to get
got my eye on
um but that's it for now
that's it for now not a lot
I talk a big game but
uh I am going to visit the uh the um
Gibson Factory soon and um hopefully
come home with a haul that'll be a lot
of fun that'll be good all right hey
we'll be right back on the 405th for
hunt 400 episodes AMA we'll be right
back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back for the last
segment of the 400 episode AMA go for it
Kelly
my friends let their kids drink alcohol
in a quote-unquote controlled setting
what are your thoughts on this
not wise and by friends you mean you I
know that you do this
no I'm just kidding um okay uh let me
let me think through this out loud
um number one like I had this I
experienced this as a kid so not as a
kid but as a
late teenager and on into college so
um I get this I get it I've been there a
couple of things let's do the pragmatic
stuff first
when it comes to teenagers there's no
such thing as a controlled setting as
much as you think there is there just is
not
um
teenagers are brilliant at navigating
boundaries they're incredible at it
um and so the idea that you're going to
create some kind of bubble that they can
do dumb stuff in or break the law in
um make wise choices in is nonsense it's
just dumb you're wrong you're incorrect
so the number two man
when I was a kid there was no cameras
anywhere ever
there was no video I mean it just wasn't
the liability a parent takes on nowadays
is madness
I can't fathom uh an adult doing that in
in this day and age with so many cameras
so many recordings so much all of it
right
um and such a increasingly litigious
Society one thing goes wrong one kid
gets sick one kid gets in a wreck one
kid starts feeling depressed one kid
fill in the blank man since crazy text
or sext somebody or asks for it and
receives it
I I don't know why anyone would put
themselves in that position
and let's take the broader view with
kids
when I look at the data
this is just the data right I like a
beer as much as the next guy I like a
great bourbon whiskey just as much as
the next guy
I'm just looking at the science part
alcohol is destroying people from the
inside out
it's destroying them at the micro level
where one or two drinks a night is
slowly eroding sleep which is slowly
eroding mental health which is slowly
eroding physical health which is slowly
eroding work performance and
relationship performance and tracks all
the way to dementia and Beyond
and alcohol on the macro level on the
deaths of Despair when we step back and
look at alcohol and then its sister
um opioids
why in the world
why in the world would you lean over to
a kid a child
and say I'll introduce you to something
that the data tells me might be a part
of killing you in the future why don't
you do that
I don't I I just I'm not gonna do that
um
parents are desperately I mean children
are in desperate need of parents who
aren't acting like their friends
children are desperate need of adults
acting like adults and being parents and
saying no as a society we've all voted
you gotta be 21. sorry gotta be 21.
um and that's not even like the motion
picture association association of
America like a group of people in some
shadowy room deciding what the rating of
a movie is as an adult cool you get to
do you get to figure that out
but we all voted as a society
I I just want to lean on that so that's
my thoughts on that Kelly what do you
think
I mean I I remember having a couple of
parents of friends of mine when I was in
high school that would let us do that
and
um but now as a parent no way
no chance if like you said every camera
every phone but I've also seen the
effects of alcohol on people in my life
and there's no chance that I would
introduce my child to that yeah or
somebody else's child without especially
without their knowledge
um because I remember growing up we had
a particular friend whose parents would
let us drink over there they were
calling our parents they never called
and said is this okay no but they were
the cool Mom right you know and now I
have no desire to be the cool Mom no
thank you no we need a generation of
parents who are don't want to be the
cool parents yeah we'll be friends but I
said I said that we're not friends no
we're not we'll be friends later you're
25 yeah it will be friends so I can't
imagine
um yeah introducing that and I feel like
I'm going to talk out of both sides of
my mouth now when I'm when I'm talking
about Downstream effects of alcohol
I would I would take my kid out and buy
in their their their supposed first
drink when they're 21. I do that right
um it's within the like I wouldn't have
problem with that
but to take a child in and say hey I
don't know I just it just feels stupid
and it's it's illegal yeah yeah yeah
period yeah on huge levels like you said
you just don't know what they're gonna
go out and do and you're right that
saying controlled setting with a
teenager is I think back to the
quote-unquote controlled settings we had
yeah that was before we had the world
hit our hands in a box where we could
take a picture and tell somebody and
then all of a sudden it's before you
know it it's all around school it's just
no way this is stupid yeah good for you
all right
um who is the person besides your
parents that you look up to or seek
advice from
um gosh
um I would categorize that in experts
and mentors and friends and so
um
experts on like I remember when covet
came out I I didn't know anything about
viruses I was super privileged I had
friends who worked in that world that
were research biologists who studied
stuff so when it came to like should I
get the vaccine or not I asked them
because they knew I didn't uh when it
comes to uh
like Landscaping things you know what
I'm good at when it comes to Landscaping
mowing that's it and dude I can work an
edger a weed eater like like I'm
incredible
but I call Rachel Freitas to come over
and lick look at my yard and she's a
friend and she's also like a renowned
expert in this so
um I ask experts for their ideas on
things I asked Dave Ramsey for personal
money uh tips right and I know most of
many people millions of people in
America would love that and
haha but I I mean I just asked him for
it um I asked Kelly for like at tattoo
aftercare information because she's an
expert she's got a thousand
um and then I got friends that I just
love and have done life with it uh I
trust and they trust me and so when I've
got a hard decision to make or a
conversation or making sure I'm seeing
something right I love asking them for
that kind of stuff
um and the mentors you know
um
men and women who have been with me for
a long long time and that I've looked up
to for a long time that I reach out to
for help and support like Darby
Dickerson or like Jonah Thompson or like
uh Randall demand oh oh I mean I could
just go on and on and on but uh men and
women who have really been important to
me in my life trajectory so um yeah I
guess experts mentors and Friends
the sun right yeah that's good not
notice the internets not the internets
no not never
the only time it's good to go to the
internets is if you're looking for stuff
that I'm saying then it's great you
should all run to the internet and hit
subscribe all right go for it all right
best way to stay connected to our teens
um the the research would say
be very firm hold kids strongly
accountable and be very kind
it's the combination of both of those
things and there's a four quadrants
um but ultimately it's
be a parent
and don't be an ass both of those things
together
um we often like
I've got a whole new accountable I'm
gonna wear them out what an idiot why
would you do that and I want to be cool
I want to be kind so I'm not going to
hold them accountable well that's dumb
too you can do both
you can with love in your heart say hey
we're not going to do that I as your
parent can't allow that I as your parent
I've got to make the call to this
teacher to this whatever I've got to
call this mechanic who I think's ripping
you off well I'm gonna I want to be a I
know I'm your parent so it's uh
firm and accountable and kind the thing
that I've been wrestling with lately
um
that I think all parents could really
really work on myself I'm and I put
myself number one at this top of this
list
what if we focused on being likable with
our kids if we focused on
um not again I think I've talked about
this a little bit but not turning every
every conversation into a teaching
moment and not turning every good thing
or failure thing into a moment where I
can imprint on
my oldest son uh he's almost 13 he lost
a tooth
and we were laughing he came in last
night lost a tooth we were laughing like
most kids lose that tooth when they're
eight and he was laughing we're carrying
on
and I
pulled my shirt up over my head so you
couldn't see my face and I grabbed a
quarter out of like my coin jar and
I flat my wings in there
and I turned the lights on he was half
asleep he's like what are you doing
and I was like it's the tooth fairy and
inflation's bad
and I flicked a quarter on his bed and
he started dying laughing
and that he's left I just left
and that's the kind of story he's going
to tell at his deathbed that my dad was
funny and my dad was silly hey my dad
made jokes
not that my dad told me a great life
lesson after the soccer game now he's
not gonna remember any of that crap he's
gonna remember I was annoying after
sporting events
but I really have been focusing lately
on being likable
and
um that doesn't mean a a doormat that
just means
that I'm I am enjoyable to be around and
I'm finding that that's making me an
infinitely more effective parent and
really co-worker and human being but
that's a whole other conversation
I want to add into that though so the
book I was telling you about
um is about the raising boys and I find
this is for both my teens
when you want to connect with your teen
you have to go where they are that my
son is not going to go shopping with me
and he's not going to sit down and watch
a Great British Bake Off he might but
not willingly I have to do what he wants
to do right and so last night for the
last few nights he's watching this
Formula One series on Netflix I heard
it's fantastic actually it's really good
yeah but I'm watching the Formula One
series and uh over you know not long ago
we watched violent night the the oh God
it was actually great David Harbor it's
a it's a Christmas but it's super
violent violent night yeah it's great
you should put that in your parent of
the Year application I did it's but you
what we want to do and be like this is
great thanks for you know making me
watch Pride and Prejudice Mom that's not
going to work
but if I can do what he wants to do it
gains trust and I'm not making fun of it
yes you're you're participating I think
I I I like that especially around
entertainment things
and enjoyment things I also think it's
important
for my kid to come with me when we're
going to help somebody's house and do
servicey things right and so like that's
more entertainment type thing yeah I
think that's right if you're always like
no kids we're watching this because my
house my TV well you're an idiot and
you're not likable nobody wants to be
around that guy right and you're not
that guy with your friends all right and
if you are you don't have any friends
because you're an ass like nobody wants
to be around you it is important that I
know what makes my kid laugh yes and
that I know what my kid's into first of
all yes because then I'm also who I know
who his friends are and um you know my
husband every once in a while will grab
a remote and play video games with him
when he's playing online so we're
hearing the people he's talking to but
then we know about his life and it's the
same with my daughter it's different a
little bit because of her special needs
but if I want to do what she is into or
I can sit and make her watch
you know stranger things which is going
to terrify her right so I I've seen a
profound transition in my my daughter
when I just walk into her room quietly
and I don't flick the lights on and off
and start throwing her stuffed animals
around like let's let's fight in if I
just go lay on the floor and just grab
my own coloring book and get right next
to her in color and we won't say
anything for five or ten minutes
and eventually she'll say
hey today is school and she'll just
launch in right and that's right what
you're saying but and that goes back to
me just being likable and it's just
getting in their world man yeah my
daughter loves to do jigsaw puzzles and
so this weekend I just put one out and
she just came over and we don't get a
lot of peaceful enjoyment time with her
because that's just not her world but
for an hour hour and a half we just sat
and did this puzzle together because I
know that that's something she'll she'll
want to join in and I can kind of you
know it's it's something that she enjoys
so I will come do that I love it yeah so
it's just being in their world because
then you get to know who they are I love
it it's great
all right last question let's do it
piece of advice that you love to give
but find the hardest to follow
eating nutritious stuff and sleep those
are the two that man I struggle big time
um and I found my sleep getting
increasingly worse I'm gonna have to
spend some Direct Time on it um I've met
with my doctor on it a couple months ago
and he gave me some pretty harsh advice
that I haven't put into practice yet
um
but he basically told me you gotta
change your life or you're not gonna be
with us much longer so I'm gonna have to
do that eventually but yeah please do I
need a job
there's some other idiot that will be
glad to spell out their opinions Kelly
um but I so sleep and diet I just eat so
much junk food
um
uh the other one is
parenting
um showing up
uh
I often say kids they're not permission
to hurt my feelings and when I find when
I'm tired or when I'm having a season of
self-doubt or I'm just not feeling good
about myself
man my daughter can flat out
crush me
um my son can crush me my wife can say
something that crushes me and
it's easy to sit here and say you just
gotta keep showing up just gotta keep
showing up man sometimes I just want to
go get a tent and sleep in the backyard
for a few nights and so I think that's
the other hard one is just to keep
showing up I do a better job of showing
up
than I do not eating gummy candies but
we'll see
what about you
uh I feel like I'm constantly telling my
kids especially probably other people
that you know
God's gonna handle this he's gonna take
it and then boy I like to control things
like you know right now we're dealing
with the house stuff and I am trying to
control every little piece of that
and my husband keeps you know spitting
my words back at me but I'm a control
freak and I tell me more Kelly
no troll but boy I can tell other people
how you know
you just need to let that go and give
that to God and then I'm over here hold
it then you're like I am God
oh yeah
all right hey hang with us we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we wrap up today's show
the 400th episode AMA hey thanks for
doing the show with me guys
I continue to feel like the luckiest guy
in the building man
thanks for doing this show
and making sure you're employed making
sure I'm employed and that when I gave
up you know the Big Show over there that
it wasn't a bad idea this is the little
show that could we are we are
we are
and on that note
the mighty Pantera off their Vulgar
Display of Power record the song is a
mouth for war
sounds so dramatic not for war and it
goes like this Revenge I'm screaming
Revenge again wrong I've been far for
far too long I've been constantly so
frustrated I move mountains for Less
with less when I Channel my hate to
productive I don't find it hard to
impress bones and traction hands break
to hone raw energy bold and disastrous
my ears can't hear what you say to me
I'm trying to sound so hard
hold your mouth for the war use it for
what it's for speak the truth about me
determined such a great dude so great
hey I love you guys stay in school don't
do drugs